now for the second day in a row there
have been explosions of Russian air
bases deep inside the country the
incidents could be a major escalation in
the war which so far has largely
remained inside the borders of Ukraine
joining me now with more details are
defense and security analyst Michael
Clark and Michael what do we know about
these explosions well um we don't know
who caused them but we can guess that
the only beneficiary of these is is
Ukraine
um I'll put the dialogue Air Base
um there was certainly an explosion and
in Saratov the Engels 2 air base there
was a an explosion there not hugely
destructive they damaged some aircraft
but these are the bases from which
Russia's heavy bombers the bear and the
Blackjack bombers as NATO called them
these two yeah deep inside Russia and
these are the bombers that they use to
launch attacks cruise missile attacks on
Ukraine so in a sense the ukrainians
look as if they're getting back at the
bases that launch attacks on their
territory as I say it's more symbolic
than anything else but also at the near
the Kursk Air Base at kalino uh which is
the military Air Base just near the
airport occurs a big fire has broken out
and that not clear again was what caused
that fire but it's a big fuel dump fire
and again the Russians have got plenty
of fuel storage facilities
um but this is symbolically very
important Kursk is a very symbolic place
for the Russians in terms of the second
world war and that sort of cloud of
black smoke uh makes it onto all the
news channels you can't ignore that and
do we know what's caused these well
there are lots of theories and the
Russians themselves say it's this they
say that it's this old drone which is a
tuple of 141 old 1970s 80s
reconnaissance drone and the ukrainians
have been saying recently that they are
repurposing a weapon probably this one
with a small Warhead 75 kilo Warhead but
it's a reasonable size GPS navigation
and a new jet engine which will make it
go A Thousand Miles the ukrainians are
well capable of doing this because they
used to produce a lot of the weapons in
the old Soviet Union and produced
weapons before 2014 for Russia so the
could do this the only thing I can't
square with it is that the damage we've
seen at those air bases so far is not
consistent with the Warhead of 75 kilos
it looks a bit too small but we'll see
but the Russians are saying this is what
it is the Ukraine is not saying anything
okay and President Putin he's been
filmed visiting one of the sites that
was previously hit on Ukraine yes I mean
he's driven across the Kirsch Bridge the
Kersh straight Bridge which was hit on
the the 8th of October again very
symbolic Target the the road bridge part
was damaged quite badly the section was
dropped just around about there uh sorry
a bit further on from there but what's
interesting is the rail Bridge right
next to it yeah the rail Bridge runs in
parallel on the rail Bridge just beyond
the two gantries there which is where
ships go under the rail Bridge was quite
badly damaged surprisingly so and
although the road is repaired and it
obviously is open 12 mile long longest
bridge in Europe the rail Bridge still
isn't and that's what really matters to
the military because they transport
their fuel to their forces of fighting
in cursing obless and further north
that's what they need for all of their
fuel and so the problem that the
ukrainians have is that if they could
attack the Kirsch Bridge again they
could really make Crimea look vulnerable
because Crimea only has two Road Links
into the rest of Ukraine it's actually
cut off from the land pretty efficiently
just by geography and so the cursed
Bridge plus these two roads one through
omnisk and one through zankoy are the
only two links to Russian forces who are
fighting up there the ukrainians know
that although conquering Crimea would be
a big issue big problem for them they
could actually make it very vulnerable
if they could just start to cut these
Road Links and do something else about
the Kirsch Bridge they would actually
make Crimea look pretty vulnerable
interesting stuff Michael thanks very
much